actually one of the girls uh you know
very upset she went crying to the
athletic department and I don't know
what they said to her but she then was
completely on board and thought Leo
swimming was like this magical beautiful
thing like am I is there something wrong
with me for thinking that this is wrong
whatever like it worked the university
wanted us to be quiet and they did it in
a very effective way like there was
something going on in that athletic
department that wanted to keep us quiet
and I was like this is getting scary
so Paula last time I spoke to you was
making what is a woman you looked a
little different on camera anyway very
shadowy and dark and now we can uh we
can see who you are so uh what what made
you decide to
speak out publicly so the biggest thing
for me has just been I thought maybe if
I waited a year or however much time
that I've been these feelings I felt
unfairness the this is not the truth
this is not just would go away
and they never really did and I just
spent this last year just kind of living
vicariously through oh Riley's going and
doing these great things she's going to
accomplish all these things we need to
have done and she's made great strides
but I am still feeling so passionately
about this that I want to join her and I
know that the more voices we have and
I'm hoping even more people will speak
out the more voices we have the more
powerful this will be so that's really
where I am I'm ready now
um I think you know this is a really big
cause and one of the biggest things I
can be a part of and it's not just about
me it's not just about Riley it's about
fighting for women and girls across the
country and I think that's that's who
I'm here for
so that's that's kind of the end we
started at the end let's let's we'll go
we'll get back to that but let's let's
go all the way back to the beginning oh
I'm curious when did you first
find out
um
about just the issue of that males might
compete against might compete against
you as a as a female athlete do you
remember when you first found out about
that
it was the fall of 2019 at the very
beginning of my sophomore year of
college we had a team meeting actually
the meeting was led by a member of the
men's team at the time will Thomas who
informed the women's team that will
Thomas they would be transitioning to
the women's team this will not be
happening this year because NCAA rules
say I have to take HRT for a year I
didn't know what any of that was or
whatever that meant but we would we were
told the next season that will Thomas
would be joining the women's team and
again at this time still will Thomas so
Leah was not to be born yet at this
point so we were first announced that
and I kind of felt shocked I felt a
little uncomfortable but everyone around
me looked really happy and excited for
this uh member of the male men's team to
be living their true self were those
looks uh genuine or were people do they
feel like they had to pretend that they
were excited honestly I can't speak for
everyone but in my experience
a shock I think that was the biggest
thing is you know you kind of like smile
when you're uncomfortable that's how I
would have read it but again I can't
speak for every single person on my team
but that's that's how I interpreted it
and it was just a situation we're like
okay well we're gonna have to navigate
this for the next year at least we have
a year to think about it and you said
that will Thomas soon to be Leah Thomas
LED this meaning where this was all
explained to you it was interesting
because actually uh the women in the
men's team at Penn is very it's a
combined program so most things we do is
with the men's team the women were
called into the team room and we had the
meeting that I sat in on where our coach
said okay everyone sit down okay I'm
gonna pass this over to will this is
Will's meeting
so this is when you you were first told
about this male who's gonna be competing
against you by the male himself so there
wasn't a meeting before this where you
guys had a chance to ask questions
without having the guy himself right
there you didn't you didn't have that
opportunity no this was just it I just
it happened like it was September of
2019. it was it
season like we were still in pre-season
actually I don't think the official
season had even started yet and it just
announced to us just and then it was
really quick it was less than 10 minutes
and then our coaches said okay everybody
get in the pool practice is starting now
was this the first time you were
introduced to the concept of males
competing against females in in women's
sports or were you aware of it as sort
of an issue I had only heard of cases of
there was a famous case in the swimming
world of uh that's somewhere at Harvard
he transitioned from the women's to the
men's team so I'd only heard of it that
way honestly I never even really I knew
I guess it would have been a possibility
if women were going to be transitioning
into men and competing with men that of
course the other way would have been a
possibility like in back of my mind but
I never thought that that would be my
reality
I just didn't think it was an issue did
you know will Thomas before this
announcement yeah I mean not not well
not very well but acquaintance with for
sure during that period how would you
describe him I thought will was very
quiet didn't really speak much to people
that weren't close friends we didn't
really interact very much definitely not
someone I would expect to be part of
such a public Scandal if
that's the best way to put it just I've
always thought it was someone who was
very like keep to themselves
was it the same way when he came over to
the women's
no
um I think I'm not sure how much of it
was just you know change of Personality
or whatever happened or how much of it
was because there was so much media
attention and you kind of have to start
like acting that way and just more
talkative more vocal walk me through in
the early weeks and months
actually competing against or having a
male on your team what was I like first
we were kind of told that maybe uh prior
to this happening again when this was
first announced we were told maybe Leah
might be
um
might be trained changing in a different
locker room or might continue to stay in
the men's team men's locker room it was
all kind of up in the air and then I saw
the locker room chart and saw that Leah
definitely had a locker in the women's
room so that was confirmed that that was
nothing going to be happening and there
was never really a further discussion
about that so I said oh okay I guess
this is the reality to actually have a
male in the women's
Locker how did you feel about that how
did the other teammates feel about it it
was definitely uncomfortable
um I did notice a few girls going
there's a few bathroom stalls in the
bathroom and I did notice some girls
changing the bathroom stalls
um
for her practice which is never really
I've never really seen that before
me personally
um the biggest thing was just when
you're changing and there's all these
people talking in the background they're
through all these women's voices and
then all of a sudden you hear a man's
voice I'd always kind of jump a little
bit thinking oh maybe a
you know a work an employee of the
building got into locker room or was you
know taking out the trash or whatever it
might be and then I would jump and
realize oh actually that's a person on
my my team speaking it's actually just
someone who sounds very masculine did he
seem to be aware that it might make
people uncomfortable that he's in there
no I wouldn't I wouldn't say so it was
never really a conversation I will say
but I personally just try to avoid
um Leah changing like try to avoid it I
try to change as fast as possible just
to deal with it the least amount that I
could and then when it came to the
actual the actual swimming part of it
yeah so Leah actually doesn't swim the
same events as me so I never had to
directly compete against Leo which again
that's where Riley is more adequate to
speak on this because she actually lost
out on you know her places that trophy
all that
for me it was more watching my teammates
who did swim those events and what it
was like for them to lose out on the
spot on the relays to lose out on being
chosen to be taken as Meats right like
swimming is one of those Sports where
it's roster limited I think most sports
are that way where not everyone can go
to Every meet
um so there were girls that were left
off the bus
um that would have been there if uh Leah
hadn't been on the team I mean what are
those girls do they say anything do they
register any kind of protest against
that yeah actually one of the girls uh
you know very upset she went crying to
the athletic department and something in
that conversation I don't know what they
said to her but she then was completely
on board and thought Leo swimming was
like this magical beautiful thing really
yeah
it was anyone he was crying she was
crying about it I mean rightly so yes
she talks to the you said the athletic
department
she made a meeting she's like I'm going
to speak to the athletic department
about this and I said go you and she
came back from the meeting and suddenly
it was the most magical beautiful thing
that this was like were part of this
groundbreaking team there was something
going on in that athletic department
that wanted to keep us quiet and I was
like this is getting scary
did you ever find out what was said to
this uh not directly but it was two days
later that they had that formal meeting
with us and notably Leo was excluded
from this meeting they said
don't talk to the media you will regret
it
uh you will regret it yep
another thing they said is Leah swimming
is a non-negotiable
um and then they provided us with
counseling services to help us be okay
with
um to help us be okay with Leah swimming
because this this is pretty you know
it's pretty startling actually oh it's
incredibly startling being on a team you
want to be supportive right your your
job as a teammate is to support your
teammates and that's kind of the biggest
thing people had issues with saying is
you know even if you don't agree with
Leah swimming or on the women's team or
whatever you have to be supportive and
that's what teammates do but I think
back about you know all those all those
scandals like what about
um Lance Armstrong and the cycling teams
right do you think Lance Armstrong's
teammates were supposed to be supportive
of doping
right so it's there's Comes A Fine Lines
yes you support your teammates but if
you see something unjust and something
wrong you can't be quiet about it and
that's I think that's what was missing
it's of course I support my teammates I
support them in all things but if I see
something unjust I need to speak about
it what what if anything were you guys
saying to each other
about all this were you commiserating
about how outrageous and unfair it is or
was it a feeling that you can't even
talk about it to each other for fear of
punishment so prior to that meeting I I
would have one-on-one conversations with
pretty much everyone on the team
say hey like you know that I don't think
this is right yeah I don't think it's
right either
um another teammate actually said to me
I think Leah's record should have an
asterisk or someone said I think Leah
should compete exhibition or you know I
don't think this is going to go on for
much longer like someone's going to step
in and end this and I have these
conversations with so many of my
teammates I would say most people on the
team had this opinion
and then after that meeting they really
scared us it was scary and I and I was
petrified I went home that night and I
called my brother on the phone and I
said can I even talk about this with you
like am I is there something wrong with
me for thinking that this is wrong
whatever it worked the university wanted
us to be quiet and they did it in a very
effective way like they continue to just
tell us that our opinions were wrong and
that if we had an issue with it we were
the problem and it's frightening and
your future job is on the line and
everything else you want to accomplish
so of course it worked and then after
that point no one would talk about it
anymore like if they effectively you
know silenced us even within talking to
each other
you began to doubt your own instincts
about whether or not this is this is
wrong yeah I I did actually
um I'm pretty religious actually I'm
Catholic and I actually went to my
Catholic leader and I was you know am I
wrong on this and at the time it was it
was really hard for people who were
involved in the Catholic Community we
want to love and we want to be there and
I want to understand that you know
someone is in pain right like Leah
Thomas is is in pain clearly if this has
happened there's pain behind that and as
a Catholic you really want to support
that and you want to empathize with that
experience but also how can you support
something that's so unjust
and so I've really struggled with that
and it it was actually very hard for me
in my religion too where I was feeling
like I can't feel hate and I don't feel
hate towards Leah I want to make that
very clear it was really hard to to
manage that and to feel the way that I
felt
um and it was and you know even the
Catholic leaders weren't really equipped
to even uh entertain these conversations
because they had never really seen
anything like it either what did they
say to you did church leaders well he
just had said like you know it's
obviously in just and just to continue
with prayer and just you know trust that
God will guide in the right way I mean
again nothing super intense and I think
as time grew on and the Injustice
continued I think the church is at least
the local church at campus campuses
stance did grow a little stronger that
this is and Justin we do need to speak
about it but at the very beginning it
was oh I don't know if we should take a
public stance on this or I don't know if
you should speak about this publicly I
think you should just work with God
directly and not speak out I actually
did have hope through the entire season
that maybe somebody would step in and
not allow this to happen like at each
stage of each big meet like before IVs
happened I said maybe the ivy league
will step in and they didn't maybe the
NCAA will step in before the NCAA
Championship and they didn't end part of
it was I constantly kept waiting for
these institutions to do the right thing
and I honestly looking back I don't know
why I ever even trusted that they might
but I did have hope and that's kind of
what kept me through that I was hoped
that somebody would see what was correct
but it just never happened and that's
part of the reason why I'm here speaking
out is that you know these institutions
failed us and I think somebody needs to
do something about it what was the
environment on the the campus even
outside of the team because this was
Leah Thomas at this point had become a
well-known figure
and controversial to say the least it
was definitely conversation on campus I
think most people on campus that found
out I was on the swim team would want to
talk to me about it I would say most
people on campus probably agreed that it
was wrong but again voicing that is
scary especially in you know
universities are are very woke it's the
lack of a better word
um and they they want to push this
liberal agenda and they want to push
um you know all of those types of ideals
on us so that was definitely
really hard to even like find people to
have conversations with but I would let
them come to me like if people came to
me I would openly discuss
what do you say to
as I'm sure you've heard many times uh
the people on the other side of this
issue who would say that we have to let
people compete against whatever group
they identify with and if we don't it's
going to make them feel excluded or what
have you yeah I understand that and
actually I have a really easy solution
that would work great if everyone can
implement it I think there should be
women's sports meaning people who are
born female
and there should be another category
formerly known as the men's team called
open
why don't we let everyone compete with
the men
and I think I'm sure maybe some men
would be unhappy with that but the thing
is people have been talking about making
this new like non-binary or trans
category and that is just another group
where men are going to always win for
example if you look at qualifications
for the Boston Marathon which is like
the greatest Marathon everyone wants to
qualify for that they're now like a
non-binary standard which guess what is
the same time standards as the woman so
you're giving men another category to
then win and let's just say that there's
prize money associated with these three
categories men are always going to win
that middle category too so I don't
think that that necessarily is a correct
solution and again I could be wrong
that's just my personal opinion I'm sure
there's much more qualified people to
make this decision than myself but I
think that that would work in the sense
that if they're saying that they can't
compete in a category that aligns with
their Identity or whatever that means
that would work those that want to open
up women's sports are not they're not
accepting of any kind of compromise no
they're not um and that's what that's
what's so scary to me about this whole
thing and there's no discussion here and
I think this the thing that was most
important to me is I think going into
college I was always under the belief
that colleges were a place of free
speech right um Candace actually spoke
Candace Owens actually spoke at the
University of Pennsylvania my freshman
year and I said that great this is what
this is about we can have conservative
voices on campus we can have liberal
voices on campus and I was so excited to
have all these opportunities to listen
to opinions from both sides like that is
what I went to college for and that's
what I thought college education was and
then as these things started going on as
I realized that they don't have that
their agenda is to have everyone believe
what they want them to believe and you
know it really became so clear to me my
senior year when all this started
happening that that is actually the case
that universities want their agenda
pushed into everyone's mind and they
don't care if you have a different
opinion because they don't want you to
have that tell me about this the you
wrote an editorial for the student
newspaper right yeah so
worked on the the Pennsylvania which is
our school run newspaper
publishing a bunch of bunch of articles
that are pro-lia we want one person to
have a dissenting Viewpoint and I was
like oh awesome right this is exactly
what I want I again I have no issue with
these people who say trans women are
women or whatever right that's their
opinion I can agree or disagree with
that but that's their own opinion and so
I said okay that's great and so
that then they kind of said I could do
it anonymously which I was like okay
awesome so we did that and then they
kind of gave me a list of rules they
said okay here are the following rules
you have to follow so I write this
article and I try to like be as
respectful as possible and I keep going
through all these edits and edits and
they're like deleting what were the
rules the rules said I couldn't refer to
transgenderism as a choice I said okay I
mean I wasn't really going to touch on
that I have to refer to everyone with
their preferred pronouns so yeah how can
you possibly
your whole argument is that someone like
Leo Thomas is a man and shouldn't be
competing against women and they're
telling you that in order to even have
the conversation you have to agree with
them to begin with I honestly ignored
the whole thing and just talked about
biology it really was more I barely even
really touched on Leah in the article to
be honest and I think you guys have a
copy we can go over it at some point but
you know it was it was really more about
the the biology and the statistics of
how the NCAA came up with their policy
for
um transgender athletes and how it was
deeply flawed I mean I I studied
engineering so I understand you know
doing studies and having hypothesis and
scientific aspects and I think a lot of
that is missing and one of the things I
noticed is that testosterone is the only
thing mentioned there are so many other
hormones in the human body why would one
singular hormone level be the
determination for someone to compete on
one side or the other like it's what and
I was like is anybody anyone even part
of this even have a scientific
background like any of you guys even
take a biology class I learned that in
my freshman year of high school in a
biology class and I think most of people
in America probably had to take bio of
their freshman year of high school too
so it was it was that was just and it
was crazy and I would write these lines
and they would just cut them out because
they'd say oh this line is like I said
at the very end I said like if we
continue to let this happen we're going
to discourage female athletes from
competing permanently and they said
that's too harsh but then eventually it
was published in some in some form yeah
and they were attracted at 45 minutes
later but luckily I did actually get a
saved copy of it published did they ever
follow up with you about what happened
nope I went out of my way to get in
contact with the guy who the editor I
was working with on the school newspaper
to ask him what happened and he dodged
my calls for about a week
and finally I got a hold of him
and he just said uh sorry I think half
the staff was threatening to quit over
this being up we don't withhold
transphobic beliefs in the daily
Pennsylvania and some blah blah blah it
was kind of like I was kind of angry I
was like an angry phone call it's like
screaming at this guy on the phone like
I mean I because I did work hard on it
like and it is I'm not I'm not like a
natural-born writer like writing a piece
I'm sure you've you've written a lot I'm
sure you know it's
like they and they asked me to do it
they wanted someone on the staff wanted
a dissenting Viewpoint and then it was
just like oh goodbye and I was like well
are we gonna make more edits so we can
make it like acceptable again at this
point there are so many edits had been
made it was barely even my piece anymore
but I was so hopeful maybe we can have
something out there that's saying maybe
this isn't fair
and they were like no we're done
and I never really talked to any of them
ever again I mean I've been uh as you
know talking about this issue for a long
time but I still when I hear stories
like this it still is somewhat
somehow I find myself being surprised by
how crazy it is I'm surprised every day
I think my biggest thing is I'm I'm a
really strong believer in free speech
um my personal history is like I'm half
Tony's and my grandfather was actually
the person who fought for free speech in
Taiwan he worked with people on both
sides both parties
um and he was the biggest believer in
free speech he had friends that he would
argue with until they were red in the
face because they disagreed so much but
they were there to have that discussion
and this entire country and many other
countries have been built on having
discussions where people disagree right
the Constitution was written over
discussions and compromises and listen
everything this country has built off of
is
arguments and discussions and Free
Speech
and I feel like we don't have that
anymore and that's what's so scary to me
about this and obviously it's unfair for
for men to compete as women but it's
also even scarier that we can't even
have a discussion about it it seems
increasingly over the last year you
mentioned Riley Gaines and others have
come out
and speaking out against this now you're
coming out
um
what do you make of the what seems to be
the momentum Gathering behind the
pushback against against all this what
do you make of that I think it's
definitely a positive sign right
obviously the second Riley started
speaking out about it I immediately got
in touch with her and she became a
friend of mine
I think there are people that are
willing to speak about it I don't think
there's enough I still think that
there's people who are never going to
change their mind about it which is
always going to be the case which I
personally find unfortunate but
you know we can only convince who we can
convince I do think there's hope I
really do I mean maybe I'm a hopeful
person I've kind of touched every single
aspect of this journey I've I've had
hope but I do see turning points I see
certain States writing into law fairness
acts and I also uh swimming the fina the
governing body of swimming has put into
law that you have to transition before
the age of 12 which no one should be
allowed to do in my opinion to compete
at the Olympic level so obviously there
are governing bodies that are taking
this seriously but I'm I don't think
we're done and I'm here to fight until
we have every single state in the United
States and every country in the world
that also believes this what do you
think needs to be done I mean what does
fighting back mean
we need to pass laws I think that's the
only way when in courts in the court
cases I know there's some notable ones
the track case in Connecticut I know
that they have a hearing coming up for
that and I think we need to just keep
telling our stories and I need to you
know encourage other people to also
speak their own right there's so many
instances of this happening that we
might not even know about right so many
different states there's so many
different sports leagues and just
encouraging the people who are going
through this to use their voice and to
voice what they know is right why is it
important for women in particular to
speak out about about this I think the
biggest thing on this is obviously men
having a voice in this is helpful right
because you know you're part of society
but I think if women can't speak out
about this themselves then what's the
point of fighting and that's kind of
part of the reason why I'm personally
speaking out is I've noticed that most
of the people speaking out about this
are in the older generations and that's
why I think it's so important for people
like me and Riley to be talking about
this because if we are the young people
that are going through this ourselves
and we can't even speak out about it
um then what's the point right if we
can't speak out and we can't tell our
truth then and why is anyone else
fighting for us like we have to to want
it ourselves for other people to fight
for us and so I think the same goes for
women women have to fight for this
themselves because it's our spaces it's
it's our Sports and I think that's
that's really powerful when the women
come together and do it and obviously
men should also speak about it I don't
disagree with that but it's really we
need to band together and we need to
speak for what's right what is your
message to any uh women out there that
maybe in the spot that you were a couple
years ago and this is happening in their
sports leagues or their bathrooms their
spaces are being invaded they're not
okay with it but they're afraid they're
nervous what's your message to them I
mean yeah I'm still I'm still really
nervous I mean it never really goes away
but I think the biggest thing is you
need to think about this is so much more
than yourself right I'm not swimming
anymore I'm not dealing with that
anymore
um I don't really have any women's faces
currently that are being invaded But I
think the biggest thing is to just fight
for those people who don't have a voice
right those younger girls the girls are
age 12 and 12 to 14 that are starting
out on these sports teams they they
don't know how to speak for themselves
they don't know what's right and what's
wrong but you have to to speak out and
have the message be told to them that
this is wrong and they're not going to
have as powerful of a voice because
they're not older and they don't have a
platform because they're you know young
girls but that's who we need to speak
out for so I think you need to think
about speaking out for everyone who
doesn't have a voice
what do you think happens to women's
sports in the next 10 years if this
trend is not reversed I just don't think
that there'll be uh real anymore
I think they'll be women biological
women or or you know females on these
teams but there won't be as many of them
and a lot of them on the way up there
will quit it's discouraging
um nobody wants to be a part of
something that you know isn't is has a
like you know you know you're gonna lose
right nobody wants to be part of
something that's unfair it's it's
discouraging and there's already been
instances of professionals who have quit
their Sports over this
so I think again I don't know what that
looks like exactly but I just don't
think they'll be truly women's sports
and then we'll have to say oh let's make
a women's team like they did you know 40
plus years ago and we'll be back right
back to where they were in the 70s are
you worried about
personal reprisals or what's gonna
happen you know what kind of what kind
of response you're going to get after
going up speaking publicly like this
yeah I'm definitely really worried
um I think obviously I know what I face
Steven speaking anonymously with people
knowing my opinion but I think it's so
much more than this and for me
personally I've come to the point where
if you can't respect my opinion and my
freedom of speech in my wanting to tell
the truth then I don't need to to worry
about your opinion of mine because you
can't respect respect what what I
believe so I think that's my feeling
towards that and obviously it is scary
and I'm sure you know others are still
afraid but unfortunately this is so much
bigger than just my own personal
feelings
well I really appreciate you speaking
out it takes a lot of courage and this
is what we need we need you we need
Marley gains we need so many more is
like like you've said I'm hoping
there'll be more yeah thanks for for
being here and talking to us thank you
so much for having me